I'm about to our breaking news now and I
can say we go back to captain rusty
aimer who's in San Clemente for us we
lost you just before that report from
Nestle Nevel as with so a thank you for
coming back to us you were talking about
how significant this find is just
elaborate more on that for us if you
would again this this would be a
significant fine if this is a genuine
Boeing part at triple seven and it's a
very simple task to find out i would
suggest authorities to send this part
immediately to go in seattle and the
engineers would be able to immediately
find out if this is a triple seven part
and once we decipher that this is a
triple seven part then we know it has to
belong to mh370 because there has not
been another crash of a triple seven in
that area and this looks like a pretty
sizable piece of an aircraft so if it
isn't a Boeing triple7 if it isn't mh370
it begs the question surely someone
would have noticed a bit of playing this
size in a crash or you know falling off
a plane or whatever it is is that not
the case yes you know what see again if
they find out that this definitely
belongs to a triple seven or part of the
trailing edge of a triple seven as you
can see this these are the trailing edge
trusses of the triple seven then the
forensic scientists could discover a lot
of clues come up with a lot of clues
from that particular part so we're
basically finding the haystack first and
then after that perhaps finding a needle
in that haystack will become much easier
I mean say that you can find out a
little bit about what's happened just
from the single paisa it has a bit more
detail about that so what evidence will
be apparent on this piece of wing if it
is in fact from mh370 for example the
scientist metallurgist could find out
what type of impact was on this
particular piece of metal were there any
residues on it there are thousands of
telltale signs that they can discover
from just that part and then also we
could perhaps find a debris field
backtracking on on this particular Park
the oceanographers could be able to find
out how the current carried this
aircraft again back track it to where
possibly the aircraft landed a crash
landed into water Christina thank you
for sharing your expertise with us this
morning's been very very insightful
that's aviation experts at captain rusty
aim of his in san clemente in california